but we begin today with news impacting
education across our state governor
steve sisselak
has signed several bills into law it
happened this morning that will impact
k-12 education
bianca holman reports from fay herron
elementary school
majority of the bills signed by governor
sisilak are signed in carson city
but this morning he signed several right
here at this elementary school in north
las vegas
these students that are here behind me
are the reason we do what we do they are
the reason
that this legislation was written
lobbied for and passed into law
if you could join me once more giving
them a huge round of applause because
they're outstanding
efforts to help nevada families and
students the future of the silver state
the governor signed the senate bill 173
known as the back on track
act helping districts address learning
loss stem from the pandemic
and ensures no child slips through the
cracks senate bill
249 allows a mental or behavioral health
professional the ability to certify an
excused absence for a student
senate bill 450 will bring classrooms
into the 21st century
providing funding to build 13 new
schools and renovate 33
existing schools and finally bill 495
took compromise implementing a 1 percent
tax on the 12th largest industry in
nevada
mining it is about our most valuable
resource here in nevada
not the gold not the silver but the
children of nevada
and 8495 really links mining
with education ab495 will provide more
than 200 million dollars
towards education reporting in north las
vegas bianca holman
8 news now